all right good morning my name is mark
Erickson and today I
very excited to talk to you about react
Redux a few things about myself I am an
answer of questions you can generally
find me under the handles at ace Marquis
and at mark Erickson answering questions
about react and redux pretty much
anywhere there's a comment box on the
Internet
I am a collector of interesting links I
have a couple large lists of links on
react and redux resources and Redux
add-ons I am a writer of very long blog
posts about ways you can use react and
redux effectively and I am a Redux
maintainer I wrote the Redux FAQ as well
as the docs section on structuring
reducers and I've actually got a little
bit of a code in the library at this
point but if you're not familiar with me
from those things then you might know me
as that guy with the Simpsons avatar
it's still kind of a running debate how
much this does or does not resemble me
but it's close enough to get the idea
across so today I want to cover a few
things we're going to look at how Redux
works with a UI layer we're going to
talk a little bit about the inspiration
for the original design of react redux
we'll spend most of our time on the
history of how the react Redux API has
evolved and then we'll talk a little bit
about the future of react redux now
we're already starting past 10 o'clock
and as you can see from the bottom right
I've got a lot of slides in here I will
go a little bit quickly and there's a
lot of content in here for 10 o'clock in
the morning I was asked to give a very
very technical talk so I'm doing that I
may skip past a couple things as we go
some of the code snippets but I will
have the slides available on my blog
later on so don't worry if you don't
catch something right away you can take
a look at it online later so let's start
by asking how do you integrate redux
with a user interface layer and that
really comes with understanding how the
create store API
actually works internally you can think
of a Redux store as an event emitter
that only has a single event some action
was dispatched not even the store state
changed but just some action was
dispatched and so if you look at that
example implementation of dispatch
internally you can see that all that it
does is it runs your route reducer
function and then it runs all of the
listener subscription callbacks and you
notice that it runs all the callbacks
every time and it also does not pass the
store state into the callbacks so when
we want to integrate redux with a user
interface there's really the same
standard series of steps that you would
follow every time you create a store you
call store dot subscribe and pass in a
subscription callback and inside that
subscription callback you need to call
store get state to get the current data
you need to extract the data that this
piece of the UI actually cares about you
update the UI with that data
once the subscription is set up you need
to actually render the UI the first time
with the initial data and then you
respond to user input by dispatching
further actions and so every Redux UI
layer is just a fancier version of this
approach so what if I want to use this
inside of react so here's a to-do list
component where I'm trying to subscribe
to the store by hand and so we can see
these same basic steps in action where
we subscribe to the store grab the two
do's and then call set state to force a
rerender same basic idea but what if we
want to start filtering the to-do list
well we can do the same kind of thing
but now we're having to add logic to
filter the to do's before we call set
state and huh we're starting to see the
same kind of logic showing up when we
first render the component and when we
render it again
so maybe we could extract that logic
into a reusable function but what
happens if the component if you want to
update or optimize how it's free
rendering we could add some logic to
manually check if the filter data has
changed at all
but this starts to get very very complex
why would you want to write this kind of
code by hand in every react component in
your application and so this really is
the point of the react Redux Connect API
it generates wrapper components that
handle this process of subscribing to
the store extracting the data that your
component cares about and only
re-rendering your component when that
data has actually changed a couple years
ago Dan Abramov put together a small
guest where he showed a miniature
version of Connect and this is that code
snippet from the gist and so it shows
that Connect
accepts map state and map dispatches
arguments returns a second function the
second function accepts your real
component as a as an argument and then
it's going to render an instance of your
component pass in the props from the
wrapper and the props generated by the
map state and map dispatch functions
when they when the wrapper component
mounts it subscribes to the store when
it unmount it unsubscribes and whenever
these in action is dispatched it's going
to force a rerender so this is really
the guts of Connect right here at least
conceptually so the key points are that
Connect generates a wrapper component
for you the wrapper gives your component
props based on the redux store every
component subscribes to the store and
this wrapper really abstracts away the
process of interacting with the store so
that your own
code doesn't have to subscribe to the
school store itself you just say here's
the data that I need and connect takes
care of it for you but what does all
this even look like inside so back into
2015 when Dan Abramov was first creating
Redux he extracted the react Redux
content content into its own repo and
the first issue he filed asked how can
we settle on a final API for react Redux
and he listed a series of constraints
that he felt that this API should follow
and so you can see things like you
should be able to connect to state
anywhere in the component tree or you
should be able to handle updates to the
from the data you should be able to
define a function that extracts the data
and we should have performance
optimizations with should component
update everywhere in the tree so over
the next couple weeks the iterated wrap
very rapidly on the API and we hit 1.0
by august there were a couple more small
breaking changes over the next couple
months and by October just a couple
months later we'd hit version 4 and
that's where things basically stayed
stable for the next year and a half so
let's look at one let's look at some of
the actual details of some of these
implementation versions so in version 4
every instance of a connected component
is a separate subscriber to the store so
if I have a connected list with 10
connected children that's 11 separate
calls to stored I subscribe and 11
different call back functions that run
every time an action is dispatched
another very key point is that the UI
updates require store State immutability
so the components are going to check to
see if the root state changed at all
they check to see if the output from
your map state functions have changed
and then they check to see if the merged
props have changed at all now how many
of you have ever accidentally mutated
State and then your components didn't
rerender afterwards okay quite a few
people this is the reason why that
happens because if the components think
that the data hasn't changed to a new
reference they assume nothing changed
and therefore there's no reason to
re-render your react components another
key point is that in version 4 the store
instance was passed down via reacts
legacy context API and now the context
API makes data available to deeply
nested components but it actually had a
flaw it would not properly update
changes to values but if you put some
kind of an event emitter into the
context nested components could
subscribe and they would receive updates
even though the referent because that
one emitter reference wasn't changing
another interesting outcome of this is
that the connected components could
accept a store as a prop and they would
subscribe to this directly now that was
mostly used for being able to unit test
connected components without having to
put a provider around them in version 4
the actual logic for updating things
when this when an action was dispatched
was directly inside the component itself
and interestingly most of the logic
actually lived in the render method of
the wrapper component an interesting
side effect of this is that it meant
that any time an action was dispatched
all the wrapper components actually had
to rerender to determine if your
component needed to render or not and
because of this render process they
needed some way to avoid updates to the
child because reacts default behavior is
that one apparent componentry renders
all of its children rerender so how can
we bail out if the child doesn't need to
be updated
well there's a little trick that you can
use react elements are normally new
objects every time you render but if you
returned the exact same child element by
reference from the render method react
will bail out and skip updating those
children and so version 4 use that
process as an optimization so I have a
few code snippets here in the interest
of time I'll skip past these but this
these snippets highlight some of the key
parts of the actual implementation
details so you can check those out in
the slides later so let's look at
version 5 so by this by the middle of
2016
Dan Abramoff had joined the react team
and was very busy with that and I had
gotten involved with the Redux project
and Dan gave the maintainer ship of that
to myself and a guy named Tim door and
shortly after that a user contributed a
couple issues in pr's where he offered
to rewrite all of connect from scratch
and the first time he filed that issue
was like that's interesting why would
you want to do that what we have works
just fine but we kept talking and
iterating through this process and he
eventually proved that his version was a
lot better in a lot of ways so we
iterated on that through the rest of the
year and by the end of 2018 we published
this implementation as version 5 and
actually did have a lot of performance
improvements and it fixed a lot of bugs
in the process so some interesting
points about version 5 version 4 had a
lot of recurring bugs that would only
happen in certain edge cases where it
was possible for a child component to
subscribe to the store before the parent
and if something happened like data for
a list item was deleted the child might
try to read that data from the store
even though it was gone and that could
result in an error being thrown from the
map state function
I refer to this as the zombie child bug
problem and so in version 5 we fixed
that by using this internal subscription
class to cascade the notifications
step-by-step down through the tree and
so this fixed the problems because we
ensure that a parent component always
subscribes to this store before the
children do and so if an item gets
deleted the parent will stop rendering
that child before the child can run its
map state function so this was a really
big help
version 5 also added something called
connect advanced this was really the
guts of connect but less opinionated
about how to turn store state and
wrapper props into the actual props for
the child component now it's interesting
because on the one hand we reimplemented
Connect has a certain set of options to
connect advanced on the other hand
almost nobody uses this and in fact
there's some recent discussion we're
probably going to deprecated and
eventually remove that function because
no one even knows it exists another
interesting point about version 5 is
that all the logic for determining if
the component should rerender has been
moved outside of the component itself
and into a set of custom memorized
selector functions and so all the logic
of running your map state and map
dispatch and calculating the new child
props actually happens outside of the
react component tree and we only
actually get react involved once we know
that the child component needs to
rerender and this is ultimately the
reason why version 5 was a lot faster
than version 4 so we will skip past the
code snippets again and move on to
version 6
so version 5 came out at the end of 2016
and lasted for a couple years but by
early 2018 we started having some
discussions with the react team
about this new concurrent mode thing
that they were talking about and flarn
II will be talking about that surely and
give it a lot more detail on that topic
and so one of the big concerns that the
react team expressed was this idea of
tearing what if during one render
sequence part of the component tree
reads data a from the store an action is
dispatched in the middle and now the
rest of the tree reads a different set
of data from the store you would have
two different parts of the tree
rendering with different data and Andrew
Clarke especially expressed a lot of
concerns about this problem version 5
also throughs a number of warnings in
react strict mode and when we tried to
eliminate those in a modified version 5
the performance was abysmal we couldn't
fix it and finally reacted off had
released a new conversion of their
context API in 16.3 and we wanted to
switch over to that so our goals for
version 6 we wanted to switch from old
context to new context we wanted to fix
the strict mode warnings Wow we wanted
to drop the the very clunky ref
forwarding implementation that we had
and we had the general goal of maybe we
can be more compatible with concurrent
mode somehow so I collaborated with the
user named Greg beaver on the version 6
implementation and we both kind of came
up with our own separate approaches for
how this might work we did some
comparisons and eventually settled on
Greg's implementation as the final
version and so we put out version 6 at
the end of 2018 two years after the
release of version 5 so one of the
biggest changes in version 6 is that
rather than having every component be a
separate subscriber to the store we only
had one subscriber and that was actually
in the provider component itself and it
actually passed the entire store state
down via reacts new context API and part
of the reason for this was
that by having the entire component tree
always seen the same copy of the store
state at the same time it would
eliminate that tearing problem in
addition when because we react always
rear Enders top-down we actually were
able to drop that custom subscription
class code because that's just how react
updates anyway and the new context API
always propagates updates even if you
return even if you have components that
skip updating so I thought this is great
it's all built-in to react it works for
free we can simplify our own codebase we
still use the same selector functions as
version 5 but now we actually had to
call them directly in the render method
of the wrapper component again because
you can only access data from context
directly in there and so we went up
using that same memo Eyes child element
trick from version 4 to try to optimize
how the components re render we also
dropped our width ref option and used
reacts new forward ref API so that you
could just put a ref on the wrapper
component and actually get back your own
component instance as a result so that
brings us up to version 7 when version 6
was in development we had some concerns
about performance and so I put together
a benchmarks repository that would try
to compare version 5 and version 6 and
try to make sure that things didn't
really get slower but during the
benchmarks and the development we saw
that version 6 was actually slower in
several of the scenarios now these were
very very artificial stress test
scenarios it's like how many components
can I render on screen before it starts
to slow down in some way but the goal
was to have some kind of objective
numbers that we could compare so what we
saw was that version 6 was slower in
these stress tests but our hope was that
in real-world apps we could put it out
and there wouldn't actually be a
difference but after version six is
release several people did file issues
and said that in their actual real
applications they did see slowdowns of
some kind so we started investigating
those performance issues and it really
comes down to how version 5 in version 6
handle updates in version 5 every
component subscribes the checks for
updates are done outside of react and
react only gets involved once we know
the component needs to re-render in
version 6 we always have to get react
involved because the provider is calling
set state every time there's a new state
value and even if and so that means
there's a rerender working top-down even
if no components actually care about the
change to the state and so even if react
isn't doing a lot of work in that render
that's still a lot more work than just
running a couple of selector functions
there are also some concerns about the
fact that you there was no more store as
a prop in version 6
since the connected components didn't
subscribe themselves there there was no
point in having store as a prop and so
we'd removed that and some users
expressed concerns that they couldn't
test their connected components
effectively and finally this was a
blocker for our ability to maybe create
some kind of a redux hooks API because
context always causes that component to
update there's no way to avoid
rear-ending when the context value
changes and there was a mile long thread
in the react repo where we were
discussing with some of the react team
members what an API for avoiding updates
from context might look like and
eventually a sebastian mark Baga said my
personal summary is that new context is
ready to be used for low frequency
updates it's not ready to be used as a
replacement for flux like state
propagation which was a problem because
we
using it for flux like state propagation
so that was a problem so in early
February this year I published a road
map issue saying okay we're gonna come
up with a version seven and we're gonna
fix these problems I don't know how
we're going to fix them yet but we're
gonna fix them somehow and so the
primary goals were run as least as fast
as version five bring back and fix the
problems with stores prop hopefully work
okay with concurrent react but maybe not
because it's not out yet hopefully avoid
the zombie child issues and hopefully
act as a foundation for eventually
building a hooks API so I wound up
building the alpha on this entirely by
myself I just had a couple weeks free I
was able to hack on something and put it
together and again after a lot of
discussion and iteration and alphas we
eventually put this out as a final
release in April and that is what's out
there right now so the key points for
this one we brought back direct
subscriptions so every connected
component is now subscribing to the
store directly again that did mean that
we had to bring back the custom
subscription class that we had from
version 5 I literally copy and paste it
from the version 5 code tree and so the
result of this is that version 7 is at
least as fast as version 5 in all of our
benchmarks if not faster the other
really interesting thing is that Connect
uses hooks internally previously Connect
was a class component and now it is a
function component that uses hooks the
other really interesting thing here is
that we now use reacts batched updates
API internally many of you have heard
have seen that if I call set state more
than once in a click handler react will
group those updates together into a
single
and that's because react wraps your
event callback with this batched updates
API and so we now actually use that
inside of connect so that the updates
caused by the redux dispatch are
actually batched together and cause
fewer internal rear Enders we also now
re export that function as part of our
public API so that if you're dispatching
multiple redux actions outside of react
like in a thunk or something
you can now wrap those in this batch
call and it should only cause one
rerender instead of multiple rear Enders
so let's actually look at a couple of
these code snippets real fast so you can
see that connect itself is now a
function component that uses hooks
internally for its implementation you
can see some fun logic for actually
running that selector and trying to
calculate what the new child props
should actually look like and we
actually have to force a rerender when
an action is dispatched and we've
calculated that the child props have
changed and finally we do actually use
that same memorized child element trick
except that this time we can now use
reacts built-in use memo hook to do that
work rather than trying to memorize that
logic in some separate way so that
brings us up to version 7.1 when hooks
first came out the react hooks FAQ said
that other libraries might want to
provide their own hooks like maybe some
kind of a use Redux hook or something
like that
and so like 30 seconds after the
announcement issues were being filed on
the react Redux repo saying when are you
going to give us hooks but we had to get
this version 7 done and out the door
before
we could even really consider what a
Redux hooks API might look like so there
was very very strong demand from the
community in fact at one point I put up
a poll on Twitter saying so now that
version sevens done what would people
like me to focus my time on should I
work on a reactor Redux API should I
work on improving the Redux Docs should
I work on Redux starter kit and like 85%
of people said hooks hooks it's like
okay okay I can take a hint so there
were several questions that we had to
solve what would the actual API even
look like how do you handle selectors
that need to depend on props for the
component how can we avoid this zombie
child bug again and like what if some
solution that we come up with maybe
requires es6 use like proxies so we had
several very very long discussion
threads like over 200 comments apiece
and after comparing a lot of existing
third-party implementations and some
suggestions from the community we
eventually settled on an implementation
from a user named Jonathan Ziller and we
put out our first alpha back in April
and the initial alpha had five different
hooks use selector use actions used
Redux use dispatch and use store and we
continue to iterate on the API as we
went through a couple more alphas we
dropped the use Redux hook which
basically was the equivalent of used
selector plus use actions like Connect
because it really didn't provide any
real benefit we also dropped use actions
because Dan felt that it was too much
overhead and not really helpful when
used in a hooks kind of a world and we
also changed how you selector calculates
its equality to determine if a rerender
is actually necessary
so after multiple iterations we put out
a release candidate in wait May and
we've been waiting to hear a bit of
feedback on that
and so what the what do these hooks
actually look like in action so you
would still you still need to put a
provider around your entire app same as
always but as you can see over on the
right we now have a used selector
function where you can extract data from
the store
there is a used dispatch hook that gives
you the stored dispatch reference
directly and so then I could you know
say create a quick hint a click handler
where we call dispatch and use some kind
of an action creator so hopefully it's
fairly fairly simple and lightweight and
should work pretty well in your
applications and that's why I am pleased
to announce that as of late last night
react Redux version 7.1 with hooks is
now final so III will say that as a
maintainer I have discovered that no
matter how much you ask for feedback
during + alpha or beta the best way to
get feedback on anything is to publish a
final version at which point everybody
starts filing issues that something is
broken so given that the code here is
relatively simple I'm hoping there won't
be many issues but please try it out in
your own applications like today and
told me everything works just fine ok so
what does the future hold we're still
really not sure exactly how this react
concurrent mode thing is going to work
out hopefully for any can answer some of
those questions for us it's very
possible that react Redux and concurrent
mode might not play all that wall
together we don't know we're gonna have
to wait and see as far as actual changes
to the library we're kind of hoping that
we won't need any more changes for a
while but if there is keep an eye on the
issues I'm sure there will be
discussions alright I am out of time and
I actually managed to finish things
without having hurry too much so my
slides have links to some additional
discussion and information from the docs
I'll have those up on my blog hopefully
sometime later today thank you very much
for your time and enjoy the conference
[Applause]